We don't speak to everyone in our lives in
the exact same way.
We speak to our bosses, to customers,
and to strangers quite formally,
and we speak to our friends
and family more casually.
We convey different aspects of ourselves
through our speech,
and so we change our way of speaking depending
on the identity that we’re trying to project.
We do it, for the most part, unconsciously,
and through history getting it wrong could
result in anything from slight awkwardness
to death,
depending on how badly you misjudged your speech
and who exactly you were talking to at the time.
What we say and how we say it matters.
But registers aren’t just for spoken language:
they apply to the written word too.
Now, there are people who believe all writing
on the internet should follow the same standards
as a business email.
But chatting to a friend is very different
to emailing your boss,
and the way we write reflects that.
Our online voice can have a wide variety of
"tones”,
and especially for folks who grew up with
the internet,
the need to convey tone means that there are
fairly well-agreed-upon conventions.
In standard written English, capital letters
don’t convey much actual information.
They just show proper nouns and
the beginning of sentences.
And while that might make a paragraph
easier to read,
we don’t flag those up at all
when we speak, it’s not necessary.
So in informal conversations,
those that feel like speaking,
we don’t need capital letters.
But that means online communities could
use capitals to convey
something else that does
appear in conversation: tone.
So all-caps became shouting.
Side note: put that text in a speech bubble
and a hand-lettered font
and suddenly it’s not shouting,
it’s just how comic books look.
Context matters.
Anyway: if all caps are shouting,
lowercase is calm, normal conversation.
Remove the punctuation and you get this sort
of aloof,
don’t-really-care tone that works well for
deadpan humor and irony.
Some people think all lowercase is "lazy,"
but it often takes work
on the part of those typing.
Most smartphones autocorrect it,
they capitalize proper nouns and the beginning
of sentences for you.
Turning that off or, more likely, going back
and undoing that capitalization takes effort,
and that shows that it's actually meaningful
and not just "lazy." In fact,
the rise of deliberate lowercasing
for stylistic effect
coincides with the rise of autocapitalization
on smartphones.
And on the other hand,
people will sometimes capitalize the first
letter of words For Effect.
That happened way before the internet:
Winnie-the-Pooh's author, A. A. Milne,
used that a long, long time ago and fairly often
in a way that seems
quite relatable today.
We can repeat characters to convey prosody,
rhythm and sound, through text.
We can repeat exclamation marks for more emphasis.
We can use question marks, not for questions?
but for a rising tone? That means we might
be unsure about something?
Or that we want to hedge our bets about what
we’re suggesting, maybe? And reversing that,
rhetorical questions can be marked by phrasing
them as a question,
but not having a question mark,
to show that there is no rising tone.
And then there’s the period, or the full stop
in British English. Periods show falling tone.
Which is pronounced at the end
of serious sentences.
Which is why so many people perceive the period
as a marker of being very serious, or angry.
There’s a difference between "ok"
and (breathes) "ok."
Which is fine, when everyone
understands that tone.
One of the most extreme examples is on Tumblr,
where commas instead of periods and deliberate
misspellings end up with "crytyping," which,
depending on who you talk to,
is either a way to show emotional distress,
or a way to sarcastically show emotional distress.
The conventions change fairly quickly:
now we don’t have to laboriously type out
text messages on old keypads,
“cu l8r” doesn’t appear any more.
There is no single “correct” way to write.
There are standards and conventions and registers
for different use,
and all the varieties of internet-speak
are just other registers.
They’re different, sure, but they are consistent,
and they’re understood by
those who use it.
Just maybe don’t crytype to your boss.
If you’ve ever wondered why you get ominous,
passive-aggressive,
ellipses at the end of text messages from
usually-older people,
that and a lot of other tales of internet
typography are in my co-author’s new book.
Gretchen McCulloch's Because Internet
is on sale July 23, 2019.
Links are in the description.